>> Bret: FINALLY TONIGHT, AN
UPDATE THAT MANY OF YOU HAVE
BEEN WAITING FOR, AND I MEAN
MANY OF YOU.
PANEL REGULAR NO MONTHS AGO,
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER SENT ME A
VERY NICE EMAIL THIS AFTERNOON
AND HE SAID I COULD SHARE SOME
OF THE GOOD NEWS ABOUT HIS
RECOVERY FROM MULTIPLE
SURGERIES.
HE WROTE "THE WORST, NOW,
APPEARS TO BE BEHIND ME AND I'M
FINALLY GETTING BACK ON TRACK
WITH THE REHAB SCHEDULE THAT
WILL EVENTUALLY GET ME HOME.
THE WHOLE STAFF HERE BEHIND ME,
HOPING FOR NO MORE SETBACKS AND
A SPEEDING RECOVERY.
HERE'S THE BREAKING NEWS.
CHARLES IS BEING HONORED AT THE
ISRAELI EMBASSY HERE IN
WASHINGTON TONIGHT FOR HIS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE U.S.-ISRAEL
ALLIANCE.
CHARLES SAID IN THAT EMAIL THE
HONOR IS ESPECIALLY MEANINGFUL
FOR HIM ON THIS DAY, THE DATA
U.S. EMBASSY OFFICIALLY MOVES TO
JERUSALEM.
CHARLES' SON DANIEL WILL BE HERE
IN D.C. TO ACCEPT THE AWARD ON
BEHALF OF HIS FATHER.
CONGRATULATIONS, AND YOU KNOW
YOU MADE A LOT OF WORRIED